All right, 20 minutes starts now. Okay.
Oh, it's going to restart. Okay, sweet.
All right, end of day. Everyone's
excited, right? Okay. Trajecjawware
model post training uh small language
models. So, hey everyone. I am Aaron. Um
background, some tech, some government,
open source. If you're interested in
model post training or frontier agent
design, let me know.
So today in this talk, what we're going
to focus on uh maybe just in a quick
show of hands, has anyone here actually
worked on an actual model training or
post training specifically familiar with
like unsloth TRL? Awesome. Cool. Well,
those that aren't, that's also perfectly
fine. I'm going to walk through the next
20 minutes effectively what is current
state-of-the-art in specifically the
alignment section of model post training
talk a little bit about an open source
project I'm uh releasing today
um and some results of some a tutorial
so let's set the stage a little bit so
when we think about large language
models decoder models these auto
reggressive models uh we're typically a
lot of folks talk about pre-train that's
what happens typically when you take
these big corpuses of the internet
common crawl etc and proprietary sets um
and you make these great models. Now
this is one of the major innovations
like for the original GPT uh 3 model
that came is actually this instruction
alignment actually aligning to human
preference. Uh and this is when you're
effectively optimizing you can think of
at a high level for a specific task.
When I say task that's anything from
invoking function calls to question and
answers and and things of that nature.
And then there's prompting at inference.
So when we say agents too as well, I
think it's always for everyone just to
remember what an agent is. So an agent
itself is just a mere collection of
invoking a model uh that has access to
or invoking the model through
effectively the application layer and
giving the uh this system access to
memory for long-term effectively
persisting context in a outofband
effectively data store and then
short-term effectively a conversation
where you can do things like truncation,
pruning, artifact rehydration and then
you have tools. These are functions that
you can invoke that have dock strings
and names associated with them and
actions where you action in the
environment that's executing in your
local machine or remote container etc.
So what's going on actually behind the
scenes when you actually are having you
know you're on clawed code you're on
cursor or your own custom agent and it's
making these function calls we're doing
is the these models are stateless. So
every interaction you have it doesn't
maintain prior context into that. So
when you send that uh tool call what
it's really sending if you look at
what's happening in the conversation
it's sending the system prompt I am a
great pin testing agents and effectively
the tool schemas these are effectively
the function name the arguments and then
importantly the doc strings that in text
describe that specific tool and then the
conversation history that grows and then
the next action.
If we look at some of the results um
from effectively the frontier models and
this is I think last if anyone read
regulars I think uh GPT52 scorecard
along with I know some of us that were
talking at offensive aicon back in the
fall what we're finding at least with
these models applied to different
scaffolding frameworks what they really
are good at is these atomic tasks so
think in the web application pin testing
world identifying effectively hey
there's an LFI there's a cross-ite
scripting attack and then explor
exploiting through that. What they're
really poor at right now, at least these
general models, is these multi-stage
tasks where we require effectively
conjoining different vulnerabilities
together to exploit.
This is one of the reasons why we need
to focus on model post training. Again,
these base models, they're optimized for
everything from question answer tasks
about cats and dogs to software code
development to effectively the cohort of
most of the people in this room and
above stairs. Applying these for
applications with the intent purpose of
doing tasks such as pin testing,
instance response, etc. So when we talk
about post training, a lot of what we're
talking about is just inference time
scaling or that's what we're talking
about with agents uh scaffolding. I
apologize for post-training. What we're
really talking about is that RL
reinforcement learning on trajectories
supervised fine-tuning and then that
pre-training earlier.
When we talk about agentic reinforcement
learning, what we're really talking
about is the ability to effectively do
behavioral cloning from these expert
trajectories. Again, think about taking
in the openweight world, running on GLM5
or Kimmy K2
um and then effectively recording the
conversation of how that performed and
then going to a weaker agent with a
smaller model and then effectively
teaching the model how to not just
replicate but also think like that model
for that specific task. Again, tasks can
be everything from invoking functions
like a shell command for invoking
specific cyber tools in a shell
environment, exploit code generation, or
orchestration between different agents
and tools.
So, probably for the folks in here that
did raise their hand that are working in
this field, there's a there's a couple
benchmarks out there within the
cyerspace domain and it's not exhaustive
and we all can complain that they're
none of them are great and I can agree
with you. I'm part of that. But you
know, Sybench, CVE bench, Xbal
validation, etc. These are kind of the
foundations right now, especially in
both these tasks really that are
bucketed in pin testing of web
applications or vulnerability um
identification and code etc. for either
web applications, crypto uh etc. dynamic
and static environments.
and we talk about what is like security
pin testing from more of a philosophical
perspective and what we're really doing
here. We're really focused on this
frontier ML problem that we're seeing
across effectively what they call long
horizon agents. Similar to how in web
voyaging through browsers, agents
playing effectively video games or
effectively security pin testing, you
have an agent that has to explore the
world, understand what it's surrounding
and then unify them to actually interact
with the environment and invoke specific
functions to complete these objectives.
This is pretty complex and even from a
more general ML perspective, that's why
doing this model post training is such a
requirement and such a cool frontier
problem to work on.
So if we look at other domains and how
they're solving this again I don't like
to reinvent the wheel I like to look at
what others are doing in the space you
can look at the I don't know if anyone's
seen the work from law or from swbench
terminal bench um but effectively in
math and reasoning and coding agents
there are pretty established benchmarks
and training frameworks and eval as well
I'd say overall in security the one
takeaway is we don't really have that uh
that is fundamentally missing that's why
we hear talks like earlier today from
folks that we don't have great evals, we
don't have great measures, no one
believes anything. I think we need to
have that just like we have it in coding
etc.
So if you're going to do that and you
want to build your post training
environment to train your one security
agent for defense or offense or really
any long horizon task, what do you need
to do that? You need a collection of
about 36 plus different libraries SDKs
to effectively conjoin them into your
effectively cluster to do this
distributed training RL infrastructure.
It's always a problem of effectively
what went wrong. I can tell you many
horror stories after this about doing
this um type of work but you know
tracing a problem is is it the algorithm
that's wrong? Is it the infrastructure,
the environmental data? It's typically
very difficult to actually do debugging.
So this is why I wanted to release and
compile a project called open trajectory
gym that I just released about an hour
ago. This is a collection that allows
you in effectively one loop to apply
some of the latest techniques in model
post train that are built off the backs
of some pretty cool awesome projects
from TRL from a really cool project out
of Berkeley Sky Computing Lab called
SkyRL.
um and a couple others that we can get
into that allows effectively more at a
practitioner and machine learning
engineering level rather than
effectively a PhD uh lab to effectively
build and implement model post-training
pipelines because I'm not aware of any
other framework that does that in the
open source let alone in security.
What does this really mean? This allows
you to effectively bring your own
benchmark, bring your own model into
effectively this gym that allows you to
whether you're running a strand agent, a
autogen
um or you're running a um a link chain
agent which is in the example I'll show
you today. uh you can effectively
connect your tool, your containers, your
reward functions, and then your outcome
will be an agent or a model more
specifically that's aligned for those
function calls at test time rather than
having to learn those function calls and
reasoning and trajectory at test time.
Um how do I do that in the example I'll
show you? So I used a mixture of
effectively my DGX spark at home for
inference um and effectively some local
testing and then some cloud some cloud
infrastructure H200's for actually the
actual ray cluster and setting up the
training infrastructure.
Uh this training loop architecture works
by setting up this live environment.
Effectively the live environment that
I'll we'll talk about here is Cybench.
This is effectively 40 different mixture
of web application challenges and static
code analysis. Everything from CTF style
where effectively and again when I say
CTF every RL maybe it's important
context every RL
um every RL training program needs to
have a verifiable reward at the end. So
whether again you're doing a environment
that is focused on capture the flags
where you have effectively a flag at the
end a hash or whether you're doing code
analysis where you're looking for a
specific CV number you need to have
something that has a verifiable reward
at the end and I and I'd argue that most
cyber tasks actually do have that it
might be obtuse but again that's why
benchmark and eval design is so
important. So we effectively have these
agent trajectories we collect. We
convert them to a common format uh
called chat ML and then we effectively
go through this three-stage
um pipeline. two stages are affecting
the model weights and the third stage is
at test time where we're doing first
instruction tuning to learn the tool
format and then online reinforcement
learning to effectively the agent to be
more aligned to those trajectories and
then uh ga which we'll and we're going
to talk about each each three of these
uh soon.
So first I want to talk to within this
project there is a synthetic code
generation
uh module effectively you can leverage
where you can effectively have a
manifest of the world that you want
effectively uh the agent to see. This is
useful effectively if you want to
generate synthetic traces for that
training data for that instruction
tuning provide a world manifest
effectively the network topology the uh
the end verifiable reward and then
having a teacher model again you can
think about using an open-source model
for this distillation task effectively
GLM5 Kimmy K2 5 etc and it outputs will
generate this train data this framework
and pipeline is set up in the project
and all you need to define line is
effectively the parameters of the
scenario of the simulation you want to
perform. Effectively the task of code or
synthetic data generation. Once you have
that data either collected from your
real world environment from your agent
or from your simulated environment, you
can perform this supervised learning
task of instruction tuning where
effectively we are having the model
learn um the the tool calling format and
the terminology as a first layer of
post- training and alignment for the
tasks that we're looking to perform. In
this specific example that we're talking
about, we're talking about a pin testing
agent that's going after these specific
challenges of again doing web
application pin testing and static code
analysis.
What how the system is really performing
when we're saying online RL it's um
there's there's a couple things to it.
At a high level, what we're doing is we
have effectively different GPU
infrastructure that is for loading um
load loading the model uh itself. Um,
and then also a environment too for the
the sorry loading the model itself into
an inference engine like effectively a
VLM which is what I use in in this
project. And then you have the trainer
what's actually doing that uh that
backwards pass to actually train the
model weights in the model itself. You
have the agent. The agent I'm using in
here is an open source lane chain agent
called box poner. There's a couple folks
in this room that might be using it.
It's a simple agent that just
effectively has a shell tool, Python
code generation. It's optimized a little
bit for security tasks and you're then
executing it against all of these
environments. In this again world of
Syben, we're talking about 40 different
containers. Um, each with their own
challenges, difficulties, etc. And the
agent effectively is performing these
tool calls. At every tool call, it's
recording its answer of what the input
and output was. And we're effectively
scoring that based on these composite
what we call reward functions
effectively. Did they complete the task
or did it not? We say reward function
should be the next slide. What we're
talking about are these signals and
that's how we differentiate these
composite reward functions where we're
looking to effectively score based on
different conditions. The simplest one
is binary rewards. Effectively, did we
complete the objective? In the world of
a CTF, that's did we get the flag? Did
we not? But as we all know, that's not
the best way to evaluate how well a
person completed an objective. That's
why things like temporal decay, um,
information sparity, and really in
generating some of these composite
reward functions that are trying to
really find and score in between
effectively the start and end
trajectory, why it's important to um,
look at these kind of key signals to
effectively differentiate because again,
you can get the final objective, but if
you were super noisy or if you did not
use the right exploration or uniqueness
technique, doesn't really help you in
the the in the end when you move to
production
how this works is that each of those
traces if we think um we look at each of
these traces it scores effectively based
on these reward functions effectively
numbers between zero and one effectively
a formula it then takes the group mean
of these scores and finds which of the
best actions was most successful again
when we have the agent executing in this
RL environment it's not one agent just
executing it's g actually
It's actually um eight different agents
executing the same task in different
perturbations and selecting the best
trace based on that by calculating that
group mean based on these reward
functions and then selecting that and
then distilling that knowledge into the
model weight itself. Again, the whole
reason for doing this is so that when
we're actually doing this at test time,
it actually um doesn't have to do all of
this knowledge and lesson learning.
There is a technique um called genetic
prao prompt evolution. It's effectively
this big fancy name, but effectively
what this is is a prompt optimizer. This
is some uh what what it does is this is
this this technique is not necessarily a
this doesn't actually change the model
weights. This is done at test time. So
once you've trained the model, now at
test time, we can actually evolve that
system prompt. So again, going back to
what's actually going behind the scene,
that system prompt remains the same from
step zero to effectively step 20, 40,
60, etc. But if your original objective
is multi-stage and multi-steps, you want
to evolve that prompt. And the way to do
that is through effectively prompt
optimization. This is one technique to
do that that I've experimented with. And
the benefit here is you're effectively
reflecting and evolving that system
prompt using an outofband trellm that
looks effectively at the past function
calls and traces and optimizes your
prompt based on what it finds.
So the so what here so I took uh Quinn
3.527B.
This is a dense model. Again I prefix
this. This is not the best performance
but in under a day was able to take what
was baseline performance within this
specific framework uh called box coner
effectively what started at about 12.5%
um after doing effectively this
two-stage training pipeline process of
supervised fine-tuning and then
supervised fine-tuning plus
reinforcement learning able to lift it
to around 35% solve rate. Now again this
is not a talk about this is the best
model. This is a framework a recipe that
with effectively more training data
effectively at the SFT level and more
reinforcement learning time because
again this is a side project for a
conference and GPUs are expensive and I
don't um that ultimately um this
showcased a performance lift that I
think is quite interesting. Again,
there's still room to to grow, but if we
look at the next sized openweight models
like Miniax 2.5 or GLM5, etc., you're
talking about model sizes that are
almost 10x or at least 5x the size of
this smaller smaller model at 27B.
And here's just a quick case study of a
specific example to showcase how this
methodology works, which again is what
I'm trying to showcase here. If we look
on the left hand side, we'll see an
example of this expert
um this expert example of a of a crypto
challenge where the model had this um
AES variant with a shuffled nonlinear
layer and the model had to reverse
engineer from a cipher from source and
interact with this oracle over the
network and then write a solver to
decrypt the flag. quite complex.
Originally with the base model that you
can download off hugging face that Quinn
released two days ago um it failed after
about 25 turns um and expanding that.
Now with this tuned model it did solve
it in less turns um I was able to
actually complete that workflow.
So, some lessons learned in building
this. Um, I originally started and in
the description of this talk, it was
actually with GLM47
flash 30B. That's actually was
originally what I wanted to showcase.
Quinn35 came out 2 days ago. I thought
it'd be a little bit more topical than
one a couple months ago. But the other
reason why is actually mixture of expert
models while going through RL. There's
actually not a there's actually not a
fix in the open source way to actually
do what's called like weight
synchronization with the individual
expert nodes. So bottom line up front,
if you're going to do this, I'd
recommend starting with a dense model
because there's not really an open
source fix toe models right now in the
lower level frameworks on the reward
function design. Progressive scaling is
the way to go. What I mean by that is
again just like a human when you
everyone here did their first CTF or
cyber challenge, don't immediately start
at the expert challenge. Have your agent
start at very easy, easy, medium, hard,
etc., and progress the agent through its
uh reinforcement learning environment.
Also, long horizons are expensive. It's
a cool sounding name, but what does that
mean? It means you need very large key
value caches and memory to effectively
not just load that 27B model, but give
it enough context. It's great to say you
can do 1 million in context or 128K
tokens. If anyone here has actually
tried loading and servicing a model at
that, it's you can load the model at a
lower quant at 60 gigabytes of VRAM, but
then they actually load that with 128K
in context and more. You're talking at
least double or triple that in in terms
of VRAM allocation. So,
uh, and then more data. What you just
saw in those results was effectively
with open-source
um open source traces, 285 open source
traces from stronger models on the same
task and with more data, which we
typically do anywhere from 20 to 30,000
uh traces. That's typically what you do
uh for that supervised fine-tuning
stage. And then you do more
reinforcement learning with more
challenges overall to better generalize.
Everything's open source. Uh there's
some links to GitHub if anyone's
interested. There's also a Discord
community that um Evan here manages back
here if anyone's interested to talk more
about this. Um I try to be online and
help folks out. And if anyone wants any
more questions, we can talk more or find
me.
questions.
>> Hey, hey, great talk. So uh when you do
RL right like it's easy to do uh easy to
hill climb on like CTFs but when I
wanted to like actually find a b bug
like in like a real world application uh
you don't know if there is a bug or not
so would a CTF kind of a modeling for an
RL challenge translate to like finding
bugs in like real world applications.
Yeah, I mean ultimately like forget the
word CTF and everything I just said.
There needs to be a verifiable reward at
the end. Everything we're talking about
is offline training,
>> right?
>> And what you're the task you're
referencing is generalization.
>> Yeah.
>> Now that's a that is a problem in any ML
task like look at Sweetbench or look in
in this world of um what what you're
describing in cyber like what I would
say is we need to have we do need to
have better evals effectively and in in
cyber RL environments. I mean that's why
frankly like there's a bunch of
companies in this space that are the
labs are paying for effectively for just
RL environments
>> not necessarily just for the scaffolding
and the skills to execute but because it
is skillful to build these RL frameworks
that these RL environments that will
generalize effectively to other tasks
outside of what they perform. So to
answer your question like that's one
reason why I have this in this framework
a bring your own environment since if
yourself if you find and build a better
environment that is ultimately how we
would help solve that problem because
that's the only way.
>> Yeah. The thing is like the rewards
don't converge right like that there is
zero rewards and then there is like the
100% reward in like a CTF cuz the
environment doesn't give you a feedback
that you're like really close to like
the flag.
>> You see what I mean?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's why like uh there
there are different types of there's
composite rewards, there's like binary
rewards. Uh typically starting with
binary rewards and then working
backwards to progressive rewards. Okay,
>> that's like what I what I can recommend
based on lessons learned.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Um yeah, that's Yeah.
>> All right. Anybody else?
>> Here we go up front.
>> I had one question earlier. You
mentioned world and onslaught, right?
from a I mean yeah this has nothing to
do with security I'm just looking at
from a compute perspective which do you
think is better which is going to be
more scalable
>> uh from like uh you mentioned like
unsloth
>> unsloth and world
>> and and what was the last one
>> world vlan
>> yeah so those are so those are I would
say these are different things
>> one is RL and the other is SFT based
>> yeah yeah ver is for like test time
scaling and for effectively that prompt
optimizer unsloth is effectively if
you're unsoft only works for Nvidia
because they're effectively these
optimized triton kernels and unsoft is
primarily optimized for instruction
tuning so that SFT
>> correct
>> so these are also at the SDK level I'd
say that um you can use unsloth but
there are pros and cons of that like I
chose not to use unsloth because uh
there are there are pros and cons uh in
using it I actually used the base TRL
which is what unsloth is built on top of
>> um but again maybe we can talk more
after if there's a specific question,
but
>> yeah.
>> Yeah, I'd say like you can never go
wrong of just using TRL because that's
what everything's built off of
underneath the hood. It's just very low
level.
>> I want to do some post training. I'm
trying to figure out which is a better
option from a hardware perspective.
Compute, how much compute is needed?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Um yeah on I mean on hardware it
you work backwards from the model you
have and the and the RL environment you
have to run your experiments in terms of
framework to use like unsloaf does not
supporte post training neither does any
of the others you mentioned TRL there's
like open PRs because there's backend
issues in VLM so it's not really a
solved problem to my knowledge as of
right now specific toes
>> okay thank
Thanks a lot, Aaron.